[Music]
school time
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to cultural appropriations
[Music]
this fall
six cities prepare
for two
rebels were the cars
dave the clock in your car is all wrong
it says it's 109.
yeah
it's i set it back for daylight savings
if it's 227
yeah i set it back an hour and 18
minutes for daylight savings that's what
you're supposed to do right
no that's not this this is an entire
everything about this clock is wrong
it's an entirely useless clock no it's
totally good that's what i do with
clocks like i set it back just the right
amount is that why you missed my twin
six month birthday
maybe
it's a big one i sent a cake
that stripper died
the rebels with a cause comedy tour
tickets on sale now at
louderwithcrowder.com
tour
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
speedy
[Music]
that's delicious
wonderful i have to adjust the
headphones here a little bit because
dave thank you for filling in yesterday
ahoy
my pleasure honestly yeah it's a fastest
man fastest man on his feet before
anything else yep we do have the tour
light of credit.com tour we will be
hitting phoenix
houston ahoy ohio charleston west
virginia ahoy nashville ahoy right bank
new jersey ahoy because manhattan
wouldn't have us and baltimore
and we're going to be adding some shows
because some of these are close to sold
out so you can go get your tickets now
live with credit.com slash tour you got
dave gerald a how are you i'm well how
are you i'm okay i'm okay i needed a
little bit a little bit of rest the
weekend took it out of me colorado was
great colorado was fun uh and then i
came back to the stories that we have to
deal with today elon musk's
trans ch his son his son
is uh changing uh
his son is changing her name to spite
his dad
yeah that makes sense
then we have a uh former president uh
joe biden denying uh the likelihood of
recession by the way even liberal
sources say that he's completely wrong
and one thing look there are a lot of
conspiracies going around right now
about the uh the cows dying yeah and we
need to fact check some of that both on
the left and on
the right my headphones keep going to my
left and my right it's like it's like a
john uh john lennon is number nine
that's self-important crap remember that
in the white album
i try to forget number nine it goes like
this if you're listening on audio number
nine
number nine oh best band of all time if
you play backwards on record player it
says you're right not to enjoy this yes
exactly
in a very sinister voice though
uh we'll also be by the way today uh
watching live so you guys can send your
comments in on mug club uh regarding uh
the supreme court so if anything happens
that we are missing they could be coming
down with some decisions
oh is that a comment
he's just screwing with you again i
guess let me ask you while i'm doing
that what have you heard about the dead
cows in kansas what do you think is
going on do you think that the ghost of
chavez and uh and uh bill gates are
injecting them with microchips or do you
think that maybe maybe some things are
being blown out of proportion from both
the left and the right the left wants
you to believe climate change then it's
this it's going to be a calamity
and the right wants you to believe that
this is all completely not the right but
some people want you to believe this is
all completely orchestrated and that
it's uh going to lend itself to the
supply shortage looks there is a supply
shortage coming down the chain i want to
let you know but it's not because of
2000 dead cows no okay space aliens so
so
before any of that
group of old men
i don't know if you saw this they
decided to make their voices heard as
people do now sorry did i say voices
fists they fought at home depot this
week with paint cans and shovels
[Applause]
you can kill somebody
you already paid for
it it goes back this is a weird dodge
versus ford commercial
john reap just drives up it's a hammy
harry
this is when you go get the seven
mexicans standing out front and be like
hey guys i need you in my gang right
yeah exactly
we're gonna need some more people yeah
we pay 15 an hour to put a hit out on
somebody
here's not racist have you been to home
depot that's what happens that's what it
is i mean it's almost ancillary yes
the home furnishings
uh by the way
here's the best part all of those men
you watched that right you saw that may
like pretty serious yeah hit in the head
with a paint can yes shovel
no one pressed charges they all declined
cause they're old they're old school
they're like yeah sometimes you get hit
with shovels yeah
the cops come out like what happened
here i didn't see nothing yeah sometimes
there's a hand print of white paint on
his face and he was like that when i
found him yeah no that's there's a video
though uh i don't know about maybe he'll
go get face painting at the mall yeah
people do that i do that sometimes
i get a tiger painting i get a little
whiskers yeah i get whiskers that's what
he has a meow cat stop wasting my time
bro
by the way we're a live show monday
through thursday at 10 a.m eastern if
you're not watching us uh here on
youtube if we're not here and you don't
see us here we're still streaming of
course on uh mug club yeah i have a full
extended segment today with a
representative who's uh threatening to
kill rhinos oh jeez and rumble don't
forget the rumble so monday through
thursday at 10 a.m eastern
uh okay let's get to elon musk here this
is what everyone is talking about this
morning
you follow the story
yeah i did yeah well i took a look into
it once i saw that it was on in the news
today
so let me ask you and you guys can can
comment here below
what do you think is happening here do
you think this is do you think some
people got to this uh this son of elon's
to try and uh you know do some damage
because
there are more and more stories coming
out where he's talked about the woke
mind cygnus going to destroy western
civilization because he wants twitter to
be uh an open platform i love how when
you go look at the the leftist news
sources remember that that leaked from
project veritas uh zoom call with elon
musk yeah just like we need to make sure
that it's you know open that we we don't
try and drive a narrative like oh
speech
[Laughter]
can't leave it to the people we can't
leave it to the people you plebs
so his son
elon musk's son xavier musk uh is now
identifying as a girl and filed to
change his name to vivian
jenna
wilson uh and of course uh look the
lgbtq plus community is pumped and they
do as they be
when it comes to still getting the
dollar bills and we welcome you to the
lgbtq plus community
go vivian woohoo but don't say bye bye
for your daddy's money okay because it's
very expensive
to be a girl
make sure the stock options transfer
over to your correct name because you're
going to want a seat at that board here
coming up soon
belated happy father's day papi
keep going strong and i support you and
i think it's great you have the courage
to stand up to your tyranny of your very
powerful and wealthy father what's that
the guy from wall-e
[Laughter]
meaning all of them there's a glass of
stuff that i don't know it's very
expensive to be a girl unless you know
you're a girl
there should be a tax nothing in life is
free except
what you are born as naturally that's
just something that but you have to pay
if you want to be a girl because that's
how you know that it's real
the rest of them were just pedophiles
i'm living my truth yes i lived my
fifteen thousand dollar truth here one
thousand here four thousand here 6 000
here
i bought a lot of truth i bought a lot
of truth
it's all truth that is really fake yes
what
fake can be true there's no way that guy
in the hawaiian shirt was not a pedo no
come on there's no doubt come on totally
grooming like hey welcome that little
moustache i mean honestly a part of me
respects that he owns it he just leans
right into you really did yeah you know
he just drove up in a panel van that
says free puppies in back
drives a bus for disney yeah
chocolate all over the back of it
because it's summer i gotta get air
conditioning all the dead puppies too oh
come on you're gonna be a pedo there
needs to be some buy-in buy an ice cream
truck you cheap bastard
now i tried i tried
they asked questions that's why i want
elon musk's son slash daughter to keep
the stock options so in a document here
submitted in california xavier who now
identifies as vivian said his name uh
change
the reasoning behind it was gender
identity and the fact that i no longer
live with or wish to be related to my
biological father in any way shape or
form and the surname wilson of course
comes from the mother uh
that's i think the whole point right
there california and documents filed in
california we've gotten to the bottom of
the root of the problem you left your
son in california and this is what
happens yeah no colombo needed no it's
just it's there right in california i
wonder if he wants his dad's money oh of
course
that's what we're saying keep the money
yeah keep the money just live your own
life live your truth don't let anybody
tell you what to do except you know take
the money just like you know with women
and alimony yeah you want to be you're
just you're a strong independent woman
whose husband pays for all your [ __ ]
without the access to that cash though i
would like to see if she would really do
this oh yeah
yeah there's no way this is just like a
bratty sort of thing i think in response
i know that they're gonna say that's you
know a phobic yeah well but it's not
though it's just she has time yeah he he
still i guess he or is it they're saying
she i don't care when i said cut it off
by the way i never thought i'd have to
clarify i mean cut the money off not cut
yeah cut the money off yeah well just
saying i'm not i'm not telling xavier to
do anything well no
he's got to add one well right
no it's no it's a boy becoming a girl i
thought it was a girl becoming a boy no
it's a boy becoming a girl boy too it's
xavier to vivi it's easy to get confused
because it's all hair anymore it's all
make-believe
so whatever
i'll be over here
chopping things i i just heard the story
and it already confused me three seconds
later
this is the point they want you confused
just think of penis things it's the same
as having wings yes there's no
difference between think of cockles
think of puss all right oh boy so
uh luckily
xavier though might find a new home
uh at the u.s women's soccer team
soon to be bankrupt sorry
megan rappano came out in support of
transgender athletes in sports in an
interview this sunday and by the way
that's because she doesn't have to
compete in a contact sport with them
is she still dating flavor flav yeah
rapping all the time she's 100
100 in support of trans athletes i think
people also need to understand that
sports is not the most important thing
in life right that's why you want to be
paid exactly the same amount as the men
life is the most important thing in life
we're talking about kids we're talking
about people's lives they are committing
suicide because they are being told that
they are gross and different and evil
and sinful and they can't play sports
with their friends that they grew up
with first off you know that's not true
for a couple of reasons that uh the
suicide rate doesn't really get any
better pre or post transition and we've
gone through these stats many times
zero percent grow out of it if you put
children on puberty blockers versus
anywhere from 87 to 94 depending on the
study that you use if you just do
nothing
by the way they're killing themselves
because people are saying they're gross
well jews in the holocaust didn't have
this kind of a suicide rate american
slaves didn't have this kind of a
suicide rate so just because someone
rightfully says that chas bono looks
like a douchebag jersey shore guido with
a chinstrap beard i don't think that's
why these people are offing themselves
in record numbers don't allow them to
set this narrative of well if you don't
if you don't they're going to kill
themselves it's just like an abusive
boyfriend just like an abusive husband
going if i kill myself it's your fault
no it's not
it is not your fault it's not the
doctor's fault it's not the chromosomes
fault megan rapping i went on to say
show me the evidence that trans women
are taking everyone's scholarships oh
there we go we'll go back to that are
dominating in every sport are winning
every title i'm sorry it's just not
happening no look
this is one of those reverse nirvana
fallacies okay that everyone
scholarships every sport winning every
title no no look look of course not
because this this just started yesterday
right in the realm of human history but
where they have entered sports women's
cycling women swimming women they have
done overwhelm they are
disproportionately represented at the
upper echelons of these sports so saying
that it isn't bad yet
because we haven't done it therefore
let's just try it and see what happens
you could use that for anything yeah you
could use that for anything yeah well
it's the same argument on election stuff
oh show me the fraud it's like oh do you
wait to protect a bank until there's a
robbery no you try to limit this thing
before it happens and this comes in
response to fina or whatever it was
banning this
transgender swimmers after the age of 12
if you transition after age 12 you can't
compete in these you know olympics and
world sports so finally something good
happened we talked about it a little bit
yesterday and this is i guess megan is
either commenting on this i don't know
when she said this but i would not be
surprised if that was the reason for it
but she's saying that it's
everybody's going against them calling
them gross you're being catered to on
every level
ever right everything now is being
geared to you right everything is being
rolled out for you everything if
somebody says anything bad about you
they can be canceled they can lose their
job like you've won you have the
narrative and don't say it's not
happening when you can make it to an
olympic level right like it may have
just happened but it got as far as it
got as far as sports can go right
exactly well check out the recent uh
change my mind actually we'll have a if
you're watching on youtube we'll have a
card on this uh where you can just click
a link on this exact topic we have the
numbers the percentages of people who
were trans who've entered sports and
what percentage they made uh up of those
in the upper tiers of these sports it's
shockingly high
more than black people in in in speed uh
focused sports okay no that's not no
that's that can
fact check that will you admonish that's
racist i guess so if you mean that i'm
making a generalized statement on race
yes black people hold uh the land speed
records for human beings uh like one
through 20. why would that be a bad
thing though it's not a bad thing but
it's still racist no that's what i'm
saying like why you're like ah yeah you
guys are fast how dare you no they don't
black people don't care it's white
people who get mad about ah it's white
suburban women it's white suburban
[ __ ] who ruin everything right now
you think black women would stand for
this crap you think black if you poll
black women think they're gonna go oh
yeah yeah we need we need trans uh men
they're gonna be like shut up
i got time don't break that [ __ ] around
here come on that's a man
you know it's true
no it's true well it's just so honest i
just want to see some go into football
and uh if they do i wouldn't mind an
entire trans detroit lions team because
maybe we'll have a chance yeah
the the trans replacements
have a chance because people won't be
tackling them quite as hard but yeah
they're all homophobic they just let
them run right you're like i don't care
if we still got a super bowl finally oh
no look seriously this is what's going
to happen you're going to have women
dominating men's sports that woman ran a
6 7 40. jeez
we don't have a dog in this fight no
women
women white suburban women you need to
start cleaning ranks
obviously if you're watching this this
is not addressed at you but you need to
start women need to start because so
many women are afraid of speaking up i
can't tell you how many women who say i
you know i came to this show because i
was afraid to talk about it and i i
finally started realizing that these
things affected me these issues affected
me but how do i discuss it with my
friends you go hey
shut up this is this is absurd do you
see what's happening yeah do you see
what's happening we can't help this we
can't fix this for you well and the
point that megan made in the opening of
it is that sports is not everything in
life life is life and it's like that's
right nobody is guaranteed an
opportunity to participate in sports
right go do something else if you can't
compete because there's not an open
category that allows whoever come one
come all to compete then go do something
else you'll be fine i wasn't allowed to
play basketball because i dunked too
much that's not true at all that's
because you kept hanging from it and
breaking no it was like it was on my
center little tikes that he kept doing
it
dave climbed up a ladder would slam it
and then with his tongue and go
is that dave in our driveway playing our
baby in basketball he just swatted my
son why is he doing that he's taunting
him now why is he playing street ball
with fisher price this just your son
beats me by seven
my son just holds his hand in the air
i love how much by seven because that
means that your son got free throws off
which means he clearly follows oh he
calls his own fouls i'd be careful
no look and this is this by the way if
you're watching right now on youtube hit
the notification bell because
subscriptions don't mean a whole lot we
don't show up in search we don't show up
and browse for most uh content hit the
notification bell it'll let you know
whenever we upload content do it it's
important also dave and i were in
colorado springs this week yes great
crowd great crowd thank you colorado
springs uh you probably could use less
shrooms before you go to a show but
mostly good now
maybe less ketamine yes even though i
guess it's legal because there's just
doctor ketamine available yeah they have
clinics now that's crazy yeah yeah
academy oh it's a whole thing but
there's actually legitimate therapeutic
use oh yeah but i'm not saying there's
not we uh in colorado this is a true
story dave and i uh and jeff and uh
brack and we were at uh bro we were at
lunch at the hotel afterward and this
lady came up with say 70 72 older out
there yeah yeah in there she just came
up and she was very nice and she said
hey sorry just so you know just my
grandson noticed that one of you dropped
your your room key a hotel room key and
of course we looked around of course it
was dave because you know he was a slob
it wasn't me though it was your key no
it was uh jeff's oh well he's a celeb
too how dare you so
we go oh she goes yeah my my grandson
noticed it oh thank you thank you so
much and you turned and said well thank
you to your grandson and you looked
and they were just a girl and it was
around a little bit of a corner and so
then i kind of tilted my head around the
corner
and there was another girl and then i
couldn't see that girl and i kept trying
to see if there was one behind the first
girl right like there's something over
there that's a boy would you say the
girls were maybe between six and eight
six and eight years old probably
generous yeah that would be something
possibly younger possibly younger and it
didn't even look like a boy it was a
girl in jean shorts pink shirt just her
hair tied up and this lady went out of
her way to say grandson like we're all
just like we're not going to have a
conversation about that oh oh yeah sure
oh the two girls one of them is a boy
yeah we got it again it's white women
who want to be agreeable to all of this
because they think it's compassionate
could you imagine a black or latino
woman coming up yeah sorry no could you
imagine a black latino yes my grandson
that's a that's a boy no they'd be like
hey stop saying jordan boy yeah that's
not you're not a boy do you have a percy
okay
no you're gonna get it you're crazy
being crazy think she's a boy we're
gonna change you're gonna grow out of it
you know kids are crazy statistically
there's a 104 chance you would look over
and see a boy right yes
it was a black mother
i'm telling you you're looking at these
demographics black americans latino
hispanic americans they are becoming
more concerned on social issues are
already inherently more conservative
it's these it's these privileged white
suburban women who elect democrats they
are the only ones who would feel so
comfortable saying and by the way that
includes megan rapino whether whether
you're a lesbian or not saying oh my
grandson and i remember we were just
sitting there and i was like i got to
say something you guys said don't say
something i was like i got to say
something but then you guys all pulled
me back and i didn't say anything well i
didn't yeah i just i didn't understand
it because they were both girls in the
sense of they had like you said pigtails
braids wearing girls clothes yeah there
was nothing about them that was a
grandson was she confused was this like
no she wasn't confused no she went out
of her way to say it several times yeah
that's why it was it was more than once
and i like
yeah i didn't get it at all right and i
was thinking the same thing i'm like oh
maybe she's got you know but she didn't
i she was perfectly fine that's why she
stood up and walked over a table and
said what was happening right it wasn't
like she was like abe lincoln over there
said that you dropped your right key
well that would have been i would have
believed that more and i've been like
well fine you see well but then the
question was answered when we saw her
husband yes oh yeah him or her
your guess is as good as mine really now
yeah it was uh it was a lot colorado
yeah just caught a lot we used to love
you so uh we'll talk about on my club
too the crap they tried to pull with the
brunch that we weren't allowed to eat
yeah dude this isn't cool at all i got
into a fight with one of them
i'm a physical fight no no what happened
is they said you can't i'll just tell it
really quickly and then we'll get into
the
real fast okay here's what happened they
said we're there we're eating it's
always about buffet at these hotels
right so breakfast breakfast buffet then
they bring out chocolate cake and they
bring out what looked like you know i
don't know some kind of bread pudding
yeah and uh they say oh but that's only
for uh for brunch and uh
and the thing is at that point i just
told them and i kind of i said well but
i already touched it
she goes okay we'll take it and i will
can i have a spatula then she goes she
goes well just i'll just take it so i
take all the sheets don't don't use your
hands that's what kids do i'm like well
you could have got me a spatula
sweetheart this one's on you
she's like the chocolate cake is for
brunch and i'm like why are you bringing
it out now and just teasing me with yes
exactly so why don't you wait till this
is until breakfast is over by the way
isn't breakfast half a lunch yeah
exactly the first part can i get half a
slice of the chocolate cake yeah this is
a this is rude it was very rude it's
gonna take everything i touched but i
just touched it i just went i was like
you know what
i'll take the risk well nobody's gonna
eat all of it they're just gonna throw
some of it away now you're gonna argue
with me right it's up to you just pelt
homeless people with it
so
eat the icing donate the bottom which by
the way you throw anything in any
direction in colorado springs you will
hit a homeless person yeah yeah they
just need to drive the streets with a
power washer at midnight just shhh
it's just like zombie shirtless people
walking around in the oh man i hit like
eight nine ten like it was a rental yeah
they're on ketamine it's okay yeah i
don't know it's like they're it's like
they're importing them
so really there's a lot they live in the
mountains speaking of which uh i'm not
not meaning not speaking of which uh
last week 11 people were killed in a
cartel shooting in mexico oh wow now
here's the thing in the article among
the dead uh was very sadly a spider
monkey
the animal was characterized as a hitman
this is the article i think we had to
translate it all references available
he was wearing a ballistic vest
a camouflage fleece jacket and a diaper
imagine a human with a flak jacket and a
diaper that's a bad combination yeah
that's not does not instill confidence
seal team six with their depends you're
like this is not gonna go well right
before it's like look buddy whenever the
stuff goes down don't worry this mess
but if it doesn't you have the diaper
yeah exactly yourself in dignity if you
misgender him he's going to slit your
throat
not anymore and according to the
authorities the primate ended up with
his arms outstretched as if holding the
young man who was carrying him the
mexican prosecutor's office also
confirmed his death he was you know
protecting his homie um
when asked for comment uh of course the
monkey was shot
and uh they found out uh who did it when
asked for comment his notorious uh rival
marbles responded talk [ __ ] get shot fam
and that seems like well you know oh
geez wow
now here's the thing
cartel monkeys would be bad enough but
some gangs now are actually recruiting
bengal tigers how well you'll see a clip
this was found
in the street of a city in mexico this
last week
that's when you run
it
oh my gosh
what the heck no it's his it's his tiger
that was like you kidding me
sorry guys just training further hit wow
that is amazing
this isn't an off leash zone
there's leash laws
i mean mexico think about it there are
people in the studio who are afraid of
they're afraid of this guy it's
unbelievable to me if i saw an animal
like that walking around like worst fear
being eaten alive oh that's not my worst
worst fear outside of being sent to jail
wrongly sent to jail and convicted of
something that's mine right that's
that's one a one b or abandonment i'll
be honest i'm fighting a tree in detroit
at least once a year i'm not even joking
well they've had they have packs of
roaming wild dogs in detroit yeah but
there will be a tiger that just escapes
a drug dealer's basement and it's like
how do you get a tiger but you you can
you drank it i just thought you meant it
was like a one of your baseball players
escapes a drone oh well that too
sometimes they don't yeah those tigers
are harmless
yeah they're not gonna hurt anything
you're gonna hurt it yeah even if you
put a bat in their hand
[Laughter]
so look uh this is funny what's funny to
me is we [ __ ] about you know after uh
what was it uh
tiger uh tiger king complained about
animal cruelty here in the united states
it's just like when we talk about energy
policies you have greta thunderbird
coming and berating the united states
when they don't talk about what's going
on in india they don't talk about what's
going on in china animal cruelty is not
even something that computes in a lot of
these countries where we all have to act
as though they have beautiful cultures
that are equal uh to that of modern
western civilization hey you know what
if you feel that way then
peta support this support the use of
gang tigers
i kind of support it yeah
i mean i think it'd be fun to watch it's
a serious flex yeah yeah
it's expensive like a monkey's bet
although i do think a monkey is pretty
good too yeah the flash jacket and the
diaper i mean come on how do you even
get the j how do you get the vest though
you're like do you have anything that
would fit i don't know like uh spider
monkey yeah or like a really small child
do you have the chest measurements yeah
four yeah
yeah they have like an animal section
they're like what do you guys think you
got a panda you got a koala there yeah
it's a little too big do you have
something a little small koala king
imagine bringing those things to michael
vick's house he just thinks he's badass
but oh yeah okay try and drowning this
in the bathtub
yeah yeah i brought sheer khan [ __ ]
it's just a monkey walker then a
bulletproof vest
[ __ ] slaps michael vick give me a
coffee
michael vicks just say he goes to the
store real quick comes with just a bunch
of bananas
you're sure you go i'm so sorry monkey's
just sitting there like king louie okay
hey quick breaking news update twitter's
board unanimously approved elon musk's
44 billion dollar takeover bid oh can we
hit this do we have celebration on the
sound board no we can probably get it
okay
son of a [ __ ] yakuza you don't even
have they approved it but it doesn't
necessarily mean that the deal is going
to go through because if they can't
prove the bot number then musk will
probably yeah they're waiting on
shareholders yeah so it's still still
some time before the celebration can
offer it's one more step in the right
direction you know what he should do is
he should take over twitter and
immediately ban his son
my dad blocked me yeah well just no
block his son's new name if that
person's yeah it's just block vivian
yeah so that he has to tweet
he makes a profile of his of his
daughter just saying all the things he
wishes she would still say go lewis hey
go back buddy go back
no one's out there to watch you today
you got to be in studio he only likes to
be in here for 20 minutes all right this
brings us to uh former vice president
joe biden here's something
that happened uh um there are a lot of
words you can use to describe the united
states of america yeah
beautiful words beautiful
uh joe biden's description might be
credit where it's the most patriotic yet
really that brings us to this week in
biden wait if you have a problem
figuring out whether you're for me or
trump then you ain't black
america is a nation that can be defined
in a single word
i was going to put him
to put
if you have a problem figuring out
whether you're for me or trump then you
ain't black
all the times for my words to leave me
you mean all the times his words do
leave him well he's like he used them
all up you can describe a mirror i'm
done yeah he usually flubs setups like
that that's what's the best i love about
the view they're going you know that
trump's no spring chicken either he's 70
he's going to be 77 biden's on 81 but
biden works out every day we're not so
much concerned with his fickle liver
spotted feet as we are his brain oh yeah
does he go biking is that what he does
he does he doesn't like you see trump
he's like hey i hope he gets better no
really and by the way i'll never ride a
bike i would never ride a bike folks i
make that doesn't matter how many gears
a lot of people tell me that gears more
gears and the bike makes a better bike i
would never ride a bike because
frankly i'm an adult folks
he had a fixie a 10 speed
an 18 speed but his mind only had one
ships mine's a fixy
like a bmx with no tricks
that's not the only really dumb thing
that former vice president biden has
said here and uh this is one thing too i
want to ask you guys
what do you think
is the likelihood of a serious recession
and what are you doing and just you
don't need me to say comment
he's always going to say comment like it
has to be so on the nose with him yeah i
feel like this is a bit of a game now
within like mr bean like he has to be
like so like
[Laughter]
so uh
you think there's going to be a
recession what are you doing to prepare
for it have you saved have you uh tried
to be frugal what's your what are your
employment uh what are your employment
options look like how about your family
because it might be time to start
thinking of those uh
thinking of those realities but here is
the former vice president denying
angrily by the way which is of course a
sign of dementia unrelated because we're
on youtube the likelihood of any sort of
a recession
is even more likely than ever not the
majority of them aren't saying that come
on don't make things up okay
now you're sounding like a republican
politician i'm joking that was a joke
is that what they do we're all kidding
aside no i don't think it is
oh kidding aside it's not joking joe
he's really changing badly really
reversed on that quickly he really you
know you know how he's lying is he's
just so simple-minded he says the
opposite so for example he goes yeah
that's not a joke that means that it's
not true yeah and he says it's just so
all kidding aside it means that it was
true yes yeah come on it's not more
somebody whispered your mother your
mother's a filthy skank look all kidding
aside joking joking hey
putin actually called me and said that
uh he was gonna you know he was gonna uh
take a jet blue flight to florida and
drop a bomb that's not a joke like that
that's just well not a joke it's just
untrue come on you know what
by the way are the 70 percent of
economists predicting a recession also
just republican politicians oops
all references available at louder with
crowder.com just to be clear 30. yeah
well i'd like to meet them where they're
just like i don't know i don't know
a lot of things could happen yeah this
thing i got bitcoin yeah i have no idea
what could things you know there are too
many variables that can't be quantified
and isn't this your job i don't like
doing it yeah
i want to go to the store and pay five
bucks for eggs yeah there you go that's
not what we're gonna help oh no don't
worry i think the 30 were banking on the
fact that the housing market being red
hot is going to soften the bloat i'm not
even kidding that was written in the
article and as i was reading like yeah
because everybody wants to buy
overpriced houses when the interest rate
is ten percent right
nobody wonders people were buying them
when it was two percent yes but yes now
that you've inflated it it's like who's
like i want to lose everything and
here's the thing was watching cnn last
morning
they don't talk about it they didn't
talk about the 70 percent of economists
that's the oh no think of all the fact
checks that took place with president
donald trump things like you know when i
played i had uh i was too under par they
go actually that's not true that was a
lie whereas he says we're not we're what
are you republican we're no we're
nowhere near recession 70 of economists
if they could find one economist under
donald trump one economist who said that
the economy wasn't going well while we
were all living it knowing that it was
going well
they would have that person doing the
circuit we know it and that's the value
i will say right now you have eight
years
a former vice president biden with
barack obama then he had three with
donald trump i don't count the last year
and now you're gonna have another four
of biden guess what that is a contrast
that if you play your cards right
meaning everyone out there that's why we
do the change my mind that's why we do
the talking with people on the street
you need to have these conversations
with people because people are living in
the same world you are you just need to
remove the blinders at the media and big
tech tries to put on their eyes when you
do guess what the house of cards comes
tumbling down the approval ratings are
shockingly bad for for biden now look
polls do not dictate what is morally
correct when we're dealing with policy
if a poll says people don't think you
should be able to own a firearm that's
irrelevant polling as it relates to
performance yeah uh of
former vice president um
it's a vali it's not the only uh it's
not the only data that you include but
it's important here's the thing it
doesn't tell the full story if you look
at the quinnipiac poll it's the reliably
democratic demographics it's his
base-based base space look uh donald
trump uh former vice president joe biden
he's polling at 24 with hispanics wow 49
with blacks 22
among 18 to 34. 22
among 18 to 34 and by the way that split
uh a big part of it has to do with the
fact that you know a much higher
percentage of women would approve so
if you look at men under the ages of 18
and 34 that doesn't happen no that
doesn't happen here's the thing i i've
always said this you just you can't
really expect to win the youth vote uh
conservatives for people who don't pay
taxes you know people who aren't really
contributing at that point you can only
expect to plant the seed so that as they
go out into the real world and they get
hit with reality they start thinking
through these issues more critically
i this is outpunted the coverage that
i've tried
to provide here they're already losing
the left is already losing
teenagers and people in their 20s
i don't think that's happened
ever i'm most surprised by the black
number and that was the highest number
49 percent among blacks
wow if you lose that democrats they've
been a very reliably like and donald
trump started to kind of chip away at
that yeah and that was great all he had
to do was move the needle just a little
bit but that is a horribly low number
watch what they do though so all they
have to do is talk their way through the
midterms because most of the economists
surveyed in that article said that the
recession would not officially be
declared until next year sometime right
most people thought in the first two
quarters because you have to have a
couple of quarters you'll be living it
for you know half a year before that
player exactly you're moving into
right so what they'll say on every every
show on sunday morning on every news
channel is say we're not actually in a
recession republicans the gop are lying
to you they're fear-mongering for the
election there's gonna be another
coveted way
happened yet right right that's it
that's all it is yeah no you paying uh
you paying 19 for four ounces of chuck
roast is just a figment of your
imagination they're not declaring a
recession yet five dollar gas they're
not declaring a recession yet when you
look at the job market they're trying to
say oh we have the highest job no people
don't want to work that's also a really
big problem yeah look the 15 remember
this fight for 15. that's irrelevant now
it's irrelevant because 15 anyone can go
out and get a 15 uh 15 an hour job yeah
it doesn't mean anything
you need 20 an hour a lot of people
would argue now now they're pushing for
25 an hour and that was the point we
always made about the 15 an hour right
because artificially determining wages
just like artificially determining
suppressing interest rates creates a
bubble it creates inflation this is what
happens when the government says they're
here to help they can't fix you know why
don't we just treat
the economy at least you know everyone
always watches jurassic park that movie
was terrible but everyone always loves
jeff goldblum because of this whole
chaos theory where he says life finds a
way
why don't people apply that to the
economy into life at large only to
dinosaurs you know
the markets change there's chaos you
cannot plan every single step no and
unintended consequences every single
time it happens every single one of
these boom bust cycles that we go
through can most of the time be traced
back to the government getting in the
way or the government doing something
that makes it way way way too cheap to
get money and now people are running out
and buying all the homes that they can't
afford and the interest rate resets and
the market crashes and all of a sudden
we're dead like it's just terror
economically but the prices don't change
i mean other than gas well the blame
shifts right right so yeah there's some
shift sure at the pump right that's what
they were doing nobody was buying it the
next thing that they did is they said
okay in congress we're gonna put a bill
through that says that we need to end
price gouging by the oil companies all
of the republicans voted against it
because that's not why gas is high and
now they're coming out and saying see
republicans when you see the gas price a
hundred and five dollars to fill up your
car blame republicans they didn't vote
for this bill right that's it they're
trying to they're trying to push so that
uh brought on bill maher saying it's
actually because they were trying to pay
out their shareholders well okay there's
nothing wrong with necessarily paying
out shareholders especially after we
were dealing with covid the economy in a
recession but it is in that same breath
she said and the thing is people don't
understand the president doesn't control
us it's oil it's these speculators and i
don't know why republicans and
conservatives aren't mad about the big
wall street firms look look do you
remember the tea party some a lot of you
watching are young it started with i
believe it was rick santelli was his
name a rant about the wall street
bailouts that's why long before the
occupy
homeless yeah bastard set up in in
zuccotti
park before they set up there and they
were crapping on cop cars you had the
tea party who showed up we were there
where they were protesting the bailouts
of all kinds they weren't just
protesting the bailouts of big banks
they were protesting the bailouts of the
big automakers this is something that we
have always been on board with so when
someone says what about the big banks
you say of course i don't believe that
big banks should be bailed out either
boom done argument gone yeah but guess
what were speculators not there under
donald trump why is it now a problem
when it's the speculators why is it now
a problem when oh it's the oil companies
making they were making money and that
is why it's so bad because it is largely
a speculative market guess what happens
when you have a sitting former vice
president who says i'm going to end
fossil fuels who take 60 actions within
his first few days within his first few
days or i guess couple of months in
office including executive orders to
stop drilling what what do you think
happens in a speculative market there
what does that mean speculate
speculation when people talk about this
these speculators are forecasting the
future they're saying okay this is how
we expect the market to go that's why
it's not necessarily supply and demand
with oil this is a simplified version i
get it there are a few people out there
who are going to be day traders single
that's not exactly it that gives you a
general idea they're saying what do we
expect to happen with this market well
do you think that's if martha stewart
can make millions off of insider
training over thread count bed sheets
you don't think that the former vice
president has an influence on the oil
market when he says i am going to end it
you can't have it both ways and by that
i mean leftists you can't have it anyway
because you're wrong about all of it
there's just look there's just no proof
when trump was in office and we were
drilling here and gas was a dollar
oh right right
and everything else i'm sorry and wage
increases
and a general feeling of hope but his
twitter i hated his twitter yes yes i
looked at my ira last night lost 40
yes oh
well only if you sell right now you know
you'll be fine oh no i'm gonna hang on
to it yeah and launch it go to zero yes
hey gold it's never been worth zero hey
yeah they send you a golden bullet once
it hits the box
[Laughter]
like this seems wasteful you could have
just sent me a plain lead bullet like
well we wanted your last one to be
special yes it's like a gold watch when
you retire except it's you're you're
done enjoy like your last meal yes only
no meal and but it does go in your mouth
yes
so here's something else look we need to
call out both sides however because
sometimes why do you say the left well
there are people on the left and there
are people on the right who are wrong
about this one you guys have all heard
about what's been going on with the cows
in uh kansas and if not you know what
comment below what do you think is
happening with the cows i want you to
comment before you watch this segment
and
then come back to me yeah i'm trying to
be as even-handed as possible we
actually had gingersnap here actually
he's from kansas and called farmers
directly we spoke with them so we have
some exclusive information here people
who are cattle farmers so uh late last
week there were reports that um you know
came out that 10 000 cows in kansas had
suddenly dropped dead
it's nice of them to do it all in one
place and nice rows yeah
it's like a heatwave
burning up my cows it's like crop
circles with cows right
totally normal
okay so here's the thing you have the
news outlets and i understand this
because they blame everything on climate
change right they could just say this is
an intense heat wave ended at that right
but then when they say it's intense heat
wave climate change it forces people to
go wait hold on a second i remember the
carbon tax hold on a second
i remember the the carbon offsets hold
on a second gas prices okay you're
pushing the climate change thing i'm
going to start being a little bit
skeptical so i understand the rebound
effect but
it doesn't necessarily mean that the
conspiracies are true either there can
be a heat wave and it not be indicative
of some major cataclysmic climate change
so a lot of blue check marks on twitter
uh
don't want to believe that the heat was
to blame so john cardillo he's a blue
check mark has a few hundred thousand
followers says i know cattle ranchers in
florida texas arizona california and a
ton of other very hot places absolute bs
that those cattle in kansas died of heat
stress combine that with all these food
plants mysteriously combusting the
globalists are definitely up to
something
now look i understand why people are
reacting skeptically
you also need to do your due diligence
by the way can we have them send they
were looking for the official number of
cows that have died i know i from what i
understand it's around two thousand um
here's ivory hecker it is two thousand
who was a ger
a journalist who i guess worked at fox
news for a period of time 120 000
followers does not mean that this person
is wrong about everything or that
there's ill intent
but posted this video which is not
entirely accurate nbc news reports more
than 2 000 cattle abruptly died in
southwest kansas in the past few days as
you can see in this video lines of dead
cattle in a field the outlet that
published this video said it was up to
ten thousand cattle that died across the
board media outlets are blaming the heat
for this death but if you look at
temperatures
over the years
actually every summer
temperatures get to about that level
that they got to when these cattle died
so it's very common for those
temperatures to happen and we haven't
heard of mass cattle deaths in the past
so what really happened what really
happened well we're going to explore
that on my youtube you know one of the
first journalists ever met told me
follow the money so we're going to ask
some questions
oh boy this is one of those things
that's sort of like the jesse ventura
when people don't have answers yeah they
say like listen i want to know what
happened at 9 11 at tower 7. well what
are you saying are you saying that
george w bush was behind it with an acme
plunger i'm just asking questions i just
want to know about the facts that matter
like florida in your tap yeah what about
it i'm asking questions with my using my
pineal gland i'm off the grid watch my
show on the grid yes
[Laughter]
such a moral doesn't this like don't
that that cut out the middleman like you
don't have to line them up and punch
them in the face with a metal rod and
then process them can't you just be like
ah all right well i guess i'm taking the
damn no because i know i'm kidding
native americans that's what you know
the peaceful loving native americans
they just if they needed to eat one
buffalo they were like oh there's a
cliff let's chase all of them off of it
and we'll take one here
the birds must love us they almost
hunted them to extinction peace loving
horseback culture jail die in perfect
squares yes
so um here's the thing follow the money
i'm not seeing a lot of answers on
following the money but i will give you
some definitive answers as far as if you
were talking about disrupting the food
chain look you're talking about almost 4
million cows who die
naturally here we'll get to these causes
and we'll get to how many are butchered
throughout the year 2000 is not
the kind of number that would cause a
supply chain issues which we are running
into here's the thing my point is this
there are issues that you need to worry
about and there are supply chain issues
creating a conspiracy and maybe there is
maybe there's some foul play we don't
know about
but the data doesn't suggest that at
this point it certainly doesn't suggest
that it's anywhere near as significant
as the policy changes that we've been
seeing that have been creating inflation
and supply chain issues so
vets have been pushing back against
these conspiracies and by the way
not left-leaning vets
just to be clear here's dr
nels lindbergh
animal consultant vet explaining the
phenomenon that is not just a heat wave
it's not climate change either sometimes
conditions get so extreme it doesn't
matter how hard producers prepare
the environment the operation the
animals dr nels lindbergh is a
veterinarian who consults with feedlots
around kansas he wants people to
understand a video showing dead cattle
in southwest kansas in the ulysses area
was caused by a heat stress event the
perfect stormers we had a rain event
actually several days of rain created
some high humidity in a typically very
arid environment followed by a sharp
spike in temperatures to 100 degrees
plus with that extreme humidity and no
wind it created conditions that
overwhelmed dr nels also says overnight
temperatures didn't help nighttime lows
that didn't get very low and that's when
cattle and animals are able to dissipate
that thermal heat load from the previous
day and when they can't dissipate that
thermal heat load then it just continues
to build now i want to get some
exclusive info that we have here
actually ginger snap called some of the
farmers that he knew in kansas here's my
point
we can't all acknowledge
that the fed for example we can't all
acknowledge that centralized government
screws up all the time
by not being able to plan things
correctly centralized planning never
works and then believe a conspiracy
where they get it perfect
with these kinds of events that would
require massive cover-ups that it be
pulled off to perfection that's the only
point that i'm making i think you need
to look critically on both sides of this
issue so kansas farmers um exclusively
spoke with us backing up what dr
lindberg said here's a conservative
farmer from kansas uh who wished to stay
anonymous is it hovelland
kansas anyway javiland javiland
told us that the heat the issue was
clearly the cause he said
and this is a quote it was legit temps
over 105 most of the day and it didn't
cool down at all at night maybe got to
90 degrees you've seen the big feed
yards out there thousands of head in a
dirt corral with limited water access no
trees just heat it was just the perfect
storm honestly and when addressing
conspiracies this farmer said there's
there's way too many of us good old boys
out here meaning conservative farmers in
kansas way too many of us good old boys
out here that if something fishy
happened we would be alerting the media
now let's keep this in context too each
year there are more than 33 million
cattle slaughtered in the united states
and almost 3.9 million cattle
they're lost per year to predator
non-predator causes right over 419 000
to weather alone just to be clear so
this is something that we need if we're
talking about 2000 let's believe the
conspiracy ten thousand if people were
conspiring to disrupt the supply chain
this isn't something that they would do
hey you you know what they would do they
would lobby the government to print more
money
yeah give another 40 billion to ukraine
give another 350 million to illegal
immigrants those are the issues that are
significant i'm sorry i'm just not
buying it when it comes to 2 000 cows
i'll use the generous number that is
unsubstantiated of 10 000. when you have
420 000 weather alone every year 4
million to natural causes that can't be
slaughtered it is a drop in the bucket
and i just don't want people taking
their eye off the prize going out and
having conversations i don't want you
going out and having conversations with
other people where you sound completely
unhinged where you go it's actually
about microchips and the cows and these
that's not why the prices are going up
if you actually educate them on why we
are dealing with hyperinflation guess
what
it's impossible to argue they go yeah
that's yup i'm living it it makes sense
but if you go and the cows and the in
the and it's like okay and then you lose
them right it's all bill gates and his
synthetic beef and bill gates is a piece
of [ __ ] don't get me wrong pathetic beef
yeah
i do think that bill gates wants us all
eating no i definitely do but crickets
and plants yeah this is not evidence of
that and by the way the first guy is
saying i know cattle farmers in texas
blah blah all these other places well
listen these guys these cows don't deal
with this kind of a swing we are having
a heat spike right now by the way they
use the global warming for that remember
last year when we had kind of a cooler
summer in texas they were like ah it's
global warming causing
unseasonably cool weather it's the this
is good it was like it was global
warming then it was climate change and
then it was it's climate variation
just don't you can you just kill
yourself can you do that now what does
climate change identify as now
well it depends what are the pronouns
climate xavier change
that doesn't make any sense anymore so
anyways um
this is just most likely not what's yeah
actually affecting this i got to be
honest
i killed them cows oh why
well
it made me feel good we also are not
addressing the fact that you know about
8 000 cows per year lost to tipping
i tipped them all yeah
they were all in squares and i was like
he hates he hates cows he tips at my i
love him i give him good stock tips i
was like come on eat y'all i go look you
want to put it all in fair life
i was like
so even though people in kansas have
been very clear on what happened former
vice president joe biden did he wanted
to address the situation himself
unfortunately the conference it didn't
air
we managed to get behind the scenes
footage
of him exclusively talking about what
happened
you see what's happening with the cows
come on
putin's taking out the cows
we need to get a vaccine it's not a joke
sir we're talking about cows in kansas
not russia we were they were in kansas
but we're not in kansas anymore and you
were there and you
you were there too and you
and you were all over please get back on
message cows are dying in kansas the
farmers are concerned cow's fallen but
we also uh don't have cereal for the
cows tricks are for kids transitioning
oh my goodness you are an absolute [ __ ]
i quit
that seems to be a lot of that going
around
must be that heat wave hey look share
the show right now if you're here on
youtube because that helps the algorithm
dave is going to be doing a solo show in
columbus ohio july 15th through the 16th
and um if you check out spokane
spokane comedy club i'll be there this
summer we just added another show six
shows so uh we love you we're going to
mud club what are we talking about a mug
club again is it uh
oh the missouri senate candidate who um
basically threatens to assassinate
his rivals he wants to hunt rhino rhinos
it's a pretty rough one like look like i
get it i hate rhinos as much as the next
guy who doesn't you know hippos if
you're talking about the fat pride stuff
that's what the point is it's a hippo
with devil exactly that's all it is i
don't know and a really crappy villain
in spider-man but this is just
you'll get to see this ad it's not
something i don't even know if we can
run it on youtube because it was
censored on facebook which i don't think
it should be but uh youtube we love you
uh but we don't piss off
foreign